your doctor may recommend dialysis a
procedure that removes waste products
from your blood if your kidneys are not
functioning properly healthy kidneys
filter out waste excess fluid and
electrolytes like potassium and sodium
from the blood these waste products exit
the body through the urethra in the form
of urine if you have kidney disease
your kidneys gradually lose function
leading to an accumulation of harmful
wastes and excess fluid in your body
increased blood pressure and bone or
blood problems
dialysis can also be done to treat acute
kidney failure which occurs when your
kidneys stopped working suddenly or to
remove drugs or poisons from your body
in one type of dialysis called
hemodialysis your doctor will use a
machine called a dialyzer to clean your
blood outside your body some weeks or
months before you begin hemodialysis
your doctor will prepare a vascular
access site on your body
your doctor will create either an
arteriovenous graft or an arteriovenous
fistula to access your blood stream
to begin he or she will numb the area
with local anesthesia
to construct an arteriovenous graft your
surgeon will make a small incision in
your forearm and insert a soft plastic
tube called a graft to connect an artery
to a vein
to create an arteriovenous fistula your
surgeon will make a small incision in
your skin and connect an artery with a
vein to make a larger vessel called a
fistula
once your vascular access site has
healed your doctor can start
hemodialysis to begin your dialysis
nurse will insert two needles into your
AV fistula or graft once the circuit is
set up your blood will flow slowly out
of your body and through the dialyzer
inside the dialyzer your blood will
encounter filtering fibers and an
absorbent cleaning solution called
dialysate
the fibers will remove waste and excess
fluids and electrolytes from your blood
you're cleaned blood will emerge from
the dialyzer and continue through the
tubing back into your body through the
second needle at your access site
when your hemodialysis session is
complete the needles and tubing are
removed and you can go home
in another type of dialysis your doctor
will use the membranes lining your
abdomen called the peritoneum to clean
your blood without removing it from your
body before you begin peritoneal
dialysis you will have an operation to
implant a soft tube called a catheter
your surgeon will insert the catheter
near your belly button
creating a port through which the
dialysate will enter and leave your
abdomen each peritoneal dialysis session
is called an exchange first you will use
your catheter to fill your abdomen with
dialysate for a period of time
determined by your doctor
through the peritoneal membrane waste
products and extra fluid are
continuously drawn out of your blood
into the dialysate along with the waste
materials it absorbed the dialysate will
drain out of your abdomen into a
disposable collection bag during your
exchange